700 c'est le nombre de repas distribués
ce mardi 24 novembre par les restos du
coeur de plaisir la campagne d'hiver est
donc officiellement lancé
pour l'heure deux mille six cents repas
sont fournis par semaine pour 195
familles inscrites un nombre de
bénéficiaires et qui pourrait augmenter
c'est toute une logistique derrière
justement pour les ramasse pour tous les
lundis ont fait l'approvisionnement du
centre du national parce que le national
des restos du coeur nous nous donne des
dotations quand même parce qu'on peut
pas dire que des rats max cette année en
raison de la crise sanitaire
l'organisation a dû être adapté six
familles sont accueillies par quart
d'heure pour limiter le contact avec les
personnes sur la matinée bas
on a des créneaux ont commencé à 8h30 et
on finit à 11h45
on avait un bénévole tape compagne et
chaque famille maintenant ballet
personne passe tout seul
nos bénévoles sont derrière les tables
pour donner ont donné du café jus
d'orange ou quoi que ce soit maintenant
on peut plus maillon essentiel des
associations les bénévoles ici au centre
de plaisir ils sont une trentaine à
tourner dans l'équipe pour continuer
d'aider malgré la crise sanitaire
je me suis engagé au secteur
parce que justement il ya des besoins
malheureusement il ya encore des besoins
et on aimerait bien que ça diminue mais
ça diminue pas c'est ça le problème est
donc on a besoin de nous donc il faut
participer lors de la campagne d'été le
centre des restos du coeur de plaisir a
enregistré 30 % de fréquentation en plus
par rapport à l'année dernière